frustrated commuters across the country
may welcome tektite and Elon Musk latest
big disruptive idea how about this
underground tunnels to beat traffic
congestion last night in Los Angeles he
unveiled the first time on what he hopes
will become a network of underground
highways he says now this initial
stretches only four tests and won't be
used by the public it runs between the
headquarters of must SpaceX company and
a parking lot behind a closed business a
little more than a mile away when must
took me for a ride the other day it was
an eye-opening 4-minute journey you can
go ahead I think how fast is this this
isn't just any tunnel it's Elon Musk
tunnel and to understand why we're
speeding through it you need to go back
a couple of years when he decided he had
had enough of Los Angeles traffic
gridlock either which tries to mean you
or we will be stuck in traffic hell for
the rest of our lives
I start thinking well maybe this could
be underground this is the underground
network he envisions electric cars using
street-level elevators to drop down into
a series of tunnels autonomous
technology in the cars ensure that they
don't run into each other despite going
speeds over 125 miles an hour tunnels of
it in my view the only solution to open
congestion because we have a 2d road
network and we have buildings in 3d and
everyone wants to pile out of those
buildings and into those buildings at
the same time obviously you can have a
traffic jam
no one was building such a system so
musk formed the amusingly named boring
company and started building it himself
he hired Steve Davis to be the company's
new president Steve you're an engineer
at SpaceX you've been there for 15 years
so when Elon came to you and said I had
this idea to do what What did he say to
you go dig a hole he had no experience
doing tunnels and said I'm just gonna do
it yeah see that didn't give you pause
Clara from scratch so probably the first
day you won't be the best at it but then
you'll get better about a year ago that
company started digging what has become
today's 1.2 mile long test tunnel it's
in Hawthorne near Los Angeles unless we
can make tunnel digging at least 10
times cheaper than digging tunnels will
not be an effective means of alleviating
traffic I'll just cost too much
these are tunnel reinforcing segments
Musk's vision depends on him being able
to do it all faster and cheaper than
current industry standards
while modern subway tunnels in Los
Angeles cost around 900 million dollars
per mile he says he built this for about
ten million one way he saved money
he literally made it dirt cheap when
digging tunnels that's quite expensive
to have all this dirt
trucked off somewhere and we're like
well why don't we try to use that dirt
for something useful so we are creating
bricks on site and you can pick him up
for an advert cheap ten cents a break so
all of these bricks yeah came out of the
tunnel
yes but speeding up the process was also
a cause for concern the city of
Hawthorne granted Musk an exemption from
typical environmental impact reviews
required under California law and in
nearby neighborhoods where the tunnel
runs some residents told us they never
even heard about the project until it
was almost finished some members of the
community seemed to feel that they
didn't really have input into that
decision we actually sent letters to
everyone I think that there's only like
a radius that you have to inform people
we doubled that radius and inform people
you know anything at any situation
that's gonna be a few percentage people
like Raul
there was also grumbling from another
area the wealthier Los Angeles
neighborhood of Brentwood which is
nearby must propose second test tunnel
along busy suppo Buddha Boulevard
community groups sued the city of Los
Angeles for also granting an
environmental review waiver there in
August musk announced he was no longer
building that tunnel there something
like retired lawyers in Brentwood that
well they do is sue like literally they
just automatically sue it's like a hobby
but those lawsuits sort of shut it down
and Sepulveda did it not no we decided
that another test tunnel isn't really
needed
I'm not fazed by lawsuits
you can't go off the tracks right know
what you're saying you cannot go off the
tracks at first glance the tunnel is a
bit daunting it's only 12 feet in
diameter so it's much more
claustrophobic than most transportation
tunnels we'll be able to go like 115
miles an hour after one you're going
that fast what's to prevent it from
crashing into another car ahead of you
that's what I worry about that because
the autopilot has radar and cameras that
will automatically slow you down before
you impact another car that you would
only be allowed to go through the tunnel
on autopilot at the end of our
four-minute adventure verdict was scary
but that was cool and by the time we
started up the elevator that returned us
to the surface it'll be faster in
practice this is just going slow because
it's early days I don't want to go any
faster than what we just did no thank
you
and when it was all over it was easier
to see how this proof-of-concept tunnel
could actually be a preview of the world
to come at this point I'm confident this
can revolutionize cities and get rid of
a solar storm traffic well I had lots of
questions he's almost a very confident
young man so obviously I thought first
thing I thought about California
earthquake prone area but for anybody
worried about that and a tunnel collapse
he hasn't answered for that too he's
told me that earthquakes really do all
of their damage on the surface not
underground he says they're like waves
hitting a boat floating on top of the
ocean and that you'd rather be in a
submarine deep underwater if there's a
big storm he also points out that
historically people who were in subway
tunnels during earthquakes escaped
serious injuries like the 1968 Mexico
City quake when zero people died in the
in their subway tunnels I mean so I kept
saying but what about this what about
this what about this and he has a
question for everything I think by the
time I was done he was ready for me
that's okay you may go along now he's
been in news lately
there's a lot of controversy about his
personality it was very clear he made
that very clear to me in no uncertain
terms that's not what this conversation
was about we'd booked this interview a
long time ago but I loved how his brain
operates he looks at a problem what he
did with the Brooks is ingenious you
know the you it cost a lot of money to
take away the dirt why not
make bricks that we can sell and if you
if you're working with a non-profit or
something that is helping people you get
the bricks for free so you know he's
always thinking about how we can make it
make things better and I do I admire
that about a 1 I read what another
reporter who's gone down that tunnel is
well wrote and he said that that Batman
would have been jealous yeah that's a
good way to sum it up it's a good very
good way to put it I don't address that
we'll have cars underground we'll
probably have cars flying in the future
but something to alleviate yeah what is
this traffic and infrastructure mess
he's thinking two steps ahead there is
much more of our interview with Elon
Musk on our website you can see the wild
ride through the tunnel and here what we
talked about when it was over and he
said Gale time for you to go check it
out at CBS this morning calm